[Musique]
depuis le 15 décembre le confinement est
remplacé par un couvre feu entre 20
heures et 6 heures du matin les sorties
sont limités au strict minimum et
doivent se faire muni d'une attestation
seul le 24 décembre fait d'ailleurs
office d'exception pour fêter noël en
famille les conseiller dans certains cas
de se faire dépister avant le réveillon
dans le sud yvelines une tania aussi
yann 16 villages pour tester les
habitants des zones rurales
nadir et à chanteloup-les-vignes la
ministre délégué à la ville a rencontré
associations et élus locaux la maire de
la commune fait partie des signataires
de l'appel du 14 novembre
cris larmes pour les quartiers
prioritaires six mois après l'élection
d'ali ravet attrape ses comptes de
campagne ont été rejetés la raison ces
actions menées lors du premier
confinement avec coeur de trappes
l'association dont il était le président
l'élu est en désaccord avec cette
analyse le dossier transmis au tribunal
administratif de versailles à plaisir la
passerelle reliant la galerie auchan et
mon grand plaisir est désormais rouverte
partiellement depuis l'ouverture du
nouveau centre commercial un litige
entre les deux parties bloquer l'accès
finalement elle est ouverte de 7 heures
à 9 heures et de 19 heures à 20 heures
pour permettre de transiter vers la gare
sncf
et puis cette officialisation la colline
d'elancourt accueillera bien le vtt pour
les jo de 2024 l'épreuve
un temps menacée fait bien partie de la
dernière carte du comité d'organisation
les yvelines accueilleront également le
cyclisme sur piste et le bmx le golf le
pentathlon moderne ainsi que
l'équitation
[Musique]